Prof: Last time we
looked at Canto XV of
Inferno,
the canto of Brunetto,
the teacher of--
Dante's teacher,
and the teacher of the
Florentines,
and we pointed out the rhetoric
of the canto.
After all, Brunetto is a master
rhetorician,
so it was quite appropriate
that Dante's account of his
meeting with his teacher would
be carried out through a
careful,
very careful,
highlighting of the ambiguities
of language;
the way a language is used very
carefully to mean one thing for
one order of experience:
Brunetto's for instance,
anthropocentric,
political understanding of the
world and then Dante's own
understanding of the world which
we could call theological,
but it really means the point
of view of someone who is
questing,
who is moving and who will move
beyond Brunetto.
And how a language oscillates.
The same words seem to acquire
different meanings in those
different contexts.
In many ways,
that language would become,
that language,
that rhetoric,
which should be the instrument
of persuasion and agreement,
becomes in and of itself the
cause of two of the
misunderstandings between them,
between master and disciple.
The canto, Brunetto,
for all of its--
the intensity and poignancy of
a personal confrontation of a
disciple who meets his teacher
and in many ways shows--
even there, there is a great
deal of ambivalence,
a great deal of
acknowledgement,
a recognition of the importance
of Brunetto's teaching on him,
but, at the same time a sort of
distance taking,
leave-taking from that teaching.
That too, though,
for all of its private quality,
the quality of the great
humanistic values of
acknowledging a teaching that
shows the way to how man makes
himself eternal,
that is anthropocentric as it
can be;
that kind of aphorism,
in a way, which is the way
Dante seals the personality of
rhetoric.
Yet, it always had--or actually
has as always this--and personal
encounters do in Dante,
a political focus.
There was something a little
bit larger than their own
private story.
It is--the encounter between
them was placed within the
crisis of Florence.
The city of Florence,
the divisions between Guelfs
and Ghibellines,
and then there's also the
announcements to Dante by
Brunetto that he is going to go
into--
he's going to end up in exile.
That the comfort,
the human bonds,
the comfort of the city and
family, and what not,
even that will be denied to
him.
For Brunetto,
of course, that is also a
strategy of thinking that
Dante's own experience is really
the mirror image of his own,
because as you remember,
and I said this at the
beginning of my remarks last
time,
Brunetto also experiences exile
as he was in Roncesvalles,
the classical place of the most
traumatic experience in medieval
history,
the place where the paladin,
Roland,
in Italian, Orlando, and
the Carolingian drama,
the Charlemagne's soldiers are
defeated and Brunetto,
that's where he-- that's how he
views his own defeat in the city
of Florence.
So there was always a public
focus.
The public focus was not just a
context for their relationship,
but it was really a way of
shedding light on the very
nature of their own divisions.
It is as if the oscillations of
language that they experience in
the exchange between them are
really a consequence also of
larger divisions,
larger suspicions,
that these characters living in
Florence entertained toward each
other.
I mentioned that because I'm
going to move today to Canto
XIX.
We are taking quite a jump.
We went through XVI;
we saw the flight on the back
of Geryon or some adumbration of
that flight on the back of
Geryon.
Canto XVII, if you were to read
it on your own,
it's an extraordinary canto.
It's the only time that Virgil
leaves Dante alone and Dante has
to meet the usurers and it is as
if he had to be left without any
guidance.
It is as if he had to discover
by himself and by his own powers
what those temptations are and
what the implications of usury
would be for him.
Let me be biographical,
a biographical resonance there,
in the sense that not only the
poet is edging toward the
condition of the usurer,
engaged in illusory
recreations, illusory
productions,
but also a biographical
reference to Dante's own father
who was engaged in that sort of
activity.
Then we go through Canto XIX,
which is really a canto I don't
want to talk about now.
That's the point of my remarks
about--my recapitulations of
what I said about Brunetto.
Dante now takes a public voice,
not only he takes a--so you
have an experience of the shifts
in his own voice.
You do know the kind of romance
atmosphere and the encounter
with Francesca.
You do have the kind of
seminar-like tones that he uses
in the encounter in Limbo with
the poets of antiquity where he
either goes on talking about art
and the secrets of the craft,
etc.
Now Dante takes what I do not
hesitate to call a prophetic
voice.
He plays now,
he sees himself as a public
role.
The shift or the change,
the departure from the
political rhetorical tone used
in the encounter with Brunetto
could not be more--
could not be sharper or more
radical.
This is an argument now that
engages him as a public figure,
as it were, indeed,
as a prophet.
What does it mean to be a
prophet for Dante?
What kind of--how can one take
on this sort of voice?
How does one go on talk--how
does a prophet talk like?
One thing that you may want to
keep in mind as I go on,
to understand this canto,
is that if clearly the pattern
for all of this,
the model would be the
prophetic voice in the Bible,
the biblical prophets.
Do not make a mistake of
thinking for a moment that
prophets are those who foretell
the future;
that's not really their role.
In fact, Dante goes out of the
way,
and I'm not going to talk about
that,
we really haven't got time,
in Canto XX,
highlighting the differences as
it were between prophets and
diviners.
The diviners are those who
foretell, predict the future,
so if the prophets do not
foretell the future,
what do they do?
They are literally readers of
the present.
This is the point.
For Dante, the biblical
prophets are those who read the
present history in its unfolding
from the perspective of what
they perceive to have been God's
promise to Israel and to them.
The prophets are,
in a way and I do not--
I don't say this in any way to
degrade them,
but on the contrary,
to highlight the importance of
their intervention into the
present that you could call them
as commentators.
Those who are in the true sense
of the word, those who remember,
that's what a commentator is.
A commentator is an exercise of
memory, a way of bringing
ancient memories to bear on the
present.
That's the way Dante
understands the prophetic voice.
Another little detail before we
go on with the canto,
you do not know,
some of you may know that Dante
actually is a writer of many
epistles.
He was a letter writer.
We do not know the letters he
wrote on behalf of his patrons,
but we do know that the letters
that he wrote in his own name,
and he would be writing letters
that the array of which is--
can be sometimes moving.
For instance,
when he writes to a friend,
he would like to attend the
funeral of his friend's wife and
cannot.
He's practically begging
because he doesn't have the
adequate clothes to go to the
funeral;
so he's clearly begging for
some kind of assistance.
He writes also letters that
probably never reached their
destination.
He wrote letters,
for instance,
to the Italian cardinals who
were in conclave.
You understand what I mean when
I say "conclave."
A conclave means that they are
shut under key and kept in some
place where they can make
decisions about electing from
within themselves or from the
outside,
a pope, and they could not
agree about whom to choose.
He writes a letter,
a letter to the Italian
cardinals and he begins the
letter addressing them,
saying perhaps all of you will
wonder who is this man,
who gives him the authority to
say--
to speak to us and address us
and spur us on to action.
Doesn't he remember--this is
Dante speaking and attributing
his thoughts to the cardinals--
the possible objection to the
intervention of a layman's voice
within sacred things?
Doesn't he remember the lesson
of the biblical prophet--
which he doesn't mention--the
name that's mentioned--
who, on seeing the ark of the
alliance being carried into the
city of Jerusalem and seeing the
ark tottering,
he stretches his hand trying to
protect it,
to make sure that it won't
collapse and it breaks into
pieces?
And God intervenes and through
lightening and fulminates and
then kills him.
Dante is aware of the danger of
taking on--
that's the point--he goes on
saying,
spurring them,
saying, I'm not really touching
the ark,
I'm really spurring the oxen
who are not going anywhere.
That's the substance of the
letter, but this does not
concern us here.
But the point that concerns us
here is that in the background
to this canto where he takes on
the prophetic voice.
He's aware of the possible
profanation that he is engaged
in, in addressing as he does the
so-called simonists.
It's time to get into the canto
of the so-called simonists.
Who are the simonists?
In fact let me just--I was just
reading this little story,
"The Sisters"
of Joyce.
I have been reading that before
but I know that that is really a
story of--
I don't know how many of you
are English students,
students of English literature,
but he writes this story.
This is a story about--it's
early twentieth-century version
of simony,
and if someone of you might
want to write a paper connecting
"The Sisters,"
this beautiful gem of a story
by Joyce, and Canto XIX.
You can, and you see the
differences that--between the
two of them.
The simonists are the followers.
It's a word,
like we said the Machiavellians
for instance,
they are the followers of
Machiavelli, those who think
like Machiavelli.
The simonists are the followers
of Simon,
who was called a magus,
or a sorcerer,
or a magician,
Simon, and actually we call
this phenomenon when you have a
name that gives or sort of
creates a trend or a way of
thinking,
it's called an eponym.
I thought that you might--from
the Greek, eponym.
This is an eponym.
Simonists are the followers of
Simon, the magician.
So it's--Dante's beginning this
story with reference to a
founding event in the
constitution of the church.
It goes back to the Acts of the
Apostles where there is this
story that--
of a sorcerer,
a man engaged in witchcraft and
illusions,
Simon who wants to buy the gift
of prophecy and the power of
making miracles from Peter.
And therefore then he
challenges him to let's see who
can fly, etc.,
and they go up on a tower and
try to fly.
Simon, of course,
will go down and will die.
What Dante is doing,
he's now encountering the popes
of his own time:
Nicholas V,
Boniface VIII--one of the great
minds and a great jurist,
by the way.
In fact there are those
historians who really think that
Dante is badmouthing him,
that there's something personal
but we can't quite see.
Boniface VIII and Clement
VI--V, I'm sorry.
The three popes are under whom
Dante lived, who are engaged in
simony.
What is simony?
It's a sacrilege.
Simony is the act,
exactly like Simon in the Acts
of the Apostles,
who wanted to buy the gift of
prophecy.
It is a sin,
whereby one can go on in making
commerce of sacred things and
thereby engaging in blasphemy.
The question then is,
what does Dante think the
sacred is?
It's a constant theme in his
reflections;
it's a constant theme of his
thoughts.
What is the sacred?
How do we determine it?
What does it mean to violate
the sacred?
Simon violates the sacred.
The popes now,
who are of his own generation,
are engaged in the same kind of
blasphemy and the same kind of
profanation.
In effect, let me just give you
a little detail that you might
appreciate this ambiguity,
the other name of Peter,
St.
Peter, the guy with the two
keys we saw an illusion to him
with Canto XIII.
The other name of Peter is
Simon, so in fact he's known as
Simon Peter.
It is as if by having this too,
the sorcerer,
the magician called Simon and
the pope called Simon Peter,
and this should be--whose
successors,
the popes should be,
the first pope and the others.
He's--Dante's actually giving
us a sense of what we call,
forgive them,
the rhetorical term,
a metonymic proximity,
a contiguity,
a nearness between them.
The nearness between the
prophetic mode and the
profanation of the prophetic
mode.
How precarious is the boundary
line that divides the two?
How precarious the divided line
that separates the sacred from
the profanation of the sacred?
So this is really what Dante is
doing.
Let's see how he dramatizes all
of this.
First of all and the question
that I raised with you is,
how do prophets talk?
One thing that you will see
here is the apostrophe.
This is a canto written in
terms of apostrophes.
Look at this and we read the
canto, so I'm reading the canto.
This is for the
transcriber--Canto XIX.
"Ah, Simon Magus,"
see there is the apostrophe.
Think about why the apostrophe.
What is an apostrophe?
"You his wretched
followers who,
rapacious, prostitute for gold
and silver the things of God
which should be brides of
righteousness."
That's the definition of simony.
Viewed as an adultery,
a corruption therefore of the
chastity of the marriage between
God and the soul.
"Now must the trumpet
sound for you,
for your place is in the third
pouch.
We were now at the next tomb
and had climbed to that part of
the ridge which hangs right over
the middle of the ditch."
Another invocation we call it,
but it's--
I'm not so sure that we can
quite decide the difference
between an invocation,
which is obviously a prayer,
for an apostrophe,
a calling on,
an address, that's what the
apostrophe is.
"How great is the art Thou
showest, in Heaven,
on earth, and in the evil
world, and how justly does Thy
power dispense!
I saw along the sides and on
the bottom the livid stone full
of holes all of one size and
each was round.
They seemed to me of a width no
more or less than those that
were made in my beautiful St.
John," the baptistery of
St.
John in Florence.
These are the wells where
baptisms take place;
they're usually octagonal in
shape.
It was the eighth day,
the idea that the Resurrection
is on the eighth day.
It's the idea of history based
on the seven days of creation,
the eighth day of the
Resurrection.
"They...
were made in my beautiful St.
John as fonts for baptism,
one of which,
not many years ago,
I broke for one that was
drowning in it--
and to this I set my seal,
to clear the mind of
everyone."
What Dante is doing is
acknowledging what could have
been seen as an act of
profanation.
He broke one--which is really a
figurative,
because they are huge and I
can't believe that he could
have--
you need ten people to break
these things apart--
so it's a figurative idea that
he stretched his hand into holy
things and violated the holy
things,
but he did it and that's the
excuse he's giving.
He did it in order to save
someone's life.
There is nothing
gratuitous--that's the point,
in his own intervention as it
is called.
It's called an interventio
in sacris,
stretching the profane hands
into holy things,
into safer things.
What he is really removing
himself from is the charge that
his act may appear purely
gratuitous.
If it's not gratuitous what is
it driven by?
Where does it come from?
If it's not--one can say well
it's a gratuitous act,
which means you can dismiss it,
but this is not gratuitous.
So what is the reason behind it
and he--if he's serious enough
he should provide us the
description.
"From the mouth of each
projected,
of each projected the feet of a
sinner and the legs as far as
the calf,
and the rest was inside."
He's representing the Popes who
were here upside down,
that's the way Simon fell,
and I'll have a little story
about that too.
It was also the position that,
according to legend,
St.
Peter wanted for himself.
He asked that he be buried
upside down because he wanted to
show what the true direction
of--
for the souls are sent for the
perfection of being--
that idea that--remember in an
inverted world,
a world which is upside down
and therefore to be with the
head down,
you are really--are right side
up.
You're going toward your proper
destination.
Dante is playing with this
iconographic motif of Peter who
asks to be crucified up--
with the head upside down and
the story of Simon who,
very much like him now,
is as a punishment is with the
head upside down.
How are they punished?
In an overt parody of the
Pentecost and the flames of
fire.
You know the story of the
Pentecost: that's the story of
the Pentecost,
is the story of the gift of
language.
They come down as a rain of
fire on them,
now they have flames on their
feet.
This is what--this is the sort
of horrible turning around of
prophecy and of the gift of
languages,
meaning that we all speak
everybody else's language,
which clearly means--I'm sure
that there are polyglots among
you,
but it clearly means that we
all speak one language:
the language of charity.
And therefore we can all
understand each other that way.
"That they would have
snapped withies or ropes.
As flames on oily things,"
the oil of unction.
So it's a further illusion to
the desecration that is taking
place here,"
moves only over the outer
surface,
so it did there from the heels
to the toe.
'Who is that one?'"
Dante asks.
He wants to know who it is,
but he sees.
"Master that writhes in
his torment more than any of his
fellows,' I said,
'and is licked by a redder
flame?'
And he answered me,
'If thou wilt have me carry
thee down there by that more
sloping bank,
thou shalt know from himself of
him and of his misdeeds.'
And I, 'All is well for me that
is thy pleasure.
Thou art my Lord and knowest
that I depart not from thy will;
thou knowest too what I do not
speak.'
Then we came onto the fourth
dike, turned and descended on
our left down to the pitted and
narrow bottom,
and the good master did not set
me down from his haunch until he
brought me to the hole of him
that so lamented with his
shanks.
'Whoever thou art,' I began,
'unhappy soul that art held
upside down planted like a post,
if thou art able,
speak.'"
Now the series of inversions is
introduced here.
"I," Dante says,
"stood there like the
friar"--
he is the layman,
the changing of roles,
and the pope who is going to
be--unveil his own--
reveal his own identity in a
moment,
he is there like an assassin,
a perfidious assassin,
meaning the one who brought
faith.
That's what the word
"perfidy"
means.
"That shrives the
treacherous,"
in Italian it's the
perfido,
"assassin who after being
fixed calls him back so that he
delays his death,
and he cried."
This is one of the popes,
Nicholas, who misunderstands,
but this misunderstanding is
highly suggestive.
He's telling Dante and us that
the reigning pope while Dante's
writing,
Boniface VIII,
one of the Orsini family,
one of the great families,
Roman families,
has already arrived and he
says, "Standest thou there
already Boniface?
By several years the writing
lied to me.
Art thou so soon sated with
these gains for which thou didst
not fear to take that by guile,
the Lady Beautiful and then to
do her outrage."
This is the coming--the
accusation that Dante can launch
at the figures of power.
The prophet who takes on power
and unveils its abusers.
"I became like those that
stand as if mocked,
not comprehending the reply
made to them,
and know not what to answer.'
Then Virgil said:
'Tell him quickly,
I'm not he, I'm not he thou
thinkest,' and I answered as if
I was bidden.
At that the spirit twisted his
feet together,
then, sighing with lamenting
voice, he said to me,
'What dost thou want with me
then?
If to know who I am concerns
thee so much that thou hast come
down the bank for it,
know that I was invested with
the great mantle."
And so on.
And Dante will go on into a
general attack,
which is really the prophetic
moment.
"I do not know,"
I'm reading from lines 90 and
following,
"I do not know if on that
I was overbold when all my
answer to him was in this
strain: 'Pray,
tell me now,
how much treasure did our Lord
require of St.
Peter before He gave the keys
into his charge?
Surely he asked nothing but
"Follow me,"
nor did Peter or the others
take gold or silver from
Matthias,"
and so on.
This is Dante now the prophet.
Dante, the man who speaks
because--and he feels that he
ought to speak and that's the
distance taking from the
gratuitousness of the accusation
because all figures of authority
are lacking.
In the presence of this eclipse
of authority,
he thinks that it is incumbent
upon him to go on taking that
authority.
It's a usurpation of a voice;
it's a usurpation of authority
in order to make up for what he
thinks is missing.
The problem,
this whole question about the
confusion of orders,
the confusion between the
secular and the sacred,
the profane and the sacred,
is brought back to one great
event which was known in the
Middle Ages as the second sin of
Adam.
It was so great--you understand
what the first sin of Adam was:
the transgression of the
command given to him not to eat
of the tree--
of the forbidden tree,
the forbidden fruit of the
tree.
The event that Dante goes back
to is the event of the so-called
Donation of Constantine,
about which I want to say a few
things and then we move onto the
next cantos.
It's the Donation of
Constantine.
It refers to the fourth
century, when the emperor
Constantine, whose name I think
I have mentioned,
gave--extended,
gave the land to the pope.
In other words,
made the pope the ruler of a
secular domain.
To Dante, this was a confusion
of registers,
a confusion of
responsibilities,
that the pope should be only
engaged in spiritual pursuits
and spiritual matters.
He becomes instead involved in
secular matters.
The sin of simony is really the
problem between the--has to do
with the Donation of
Constantine.
An issue, by the way,
I will tell you why this is
important in a second.
The issue is--will be really
clarified around the fifteenth
century when two people,
two figures,
one is Cusanus,
some of you may know him.
Nicholas of Cusa went home
repeating the moral arguments
against the Donation of
Constantine as much as Dante
does here,
but the one who really proved
the falseness of the documents
with which Constantine
supposedly made the donation to
the pope was Lorenzo Valla,
with a philologist who went on
examining the language of that
text and by examining that
language,
found out that the donation was
not really--
the document had not possibly
been written in the fourth
century because it bore the
traces of eleventh-century
Latin.
And so he went on specifying
that that Donation had been a
forgery and the forgery had been
committed in a convent in the
south of France with
extraordinary linguistic
precision.
Why is this important to Dante?
Dante makes this issue of the
Donation of Constantine,
the confusion of orders,
the spiritual and the secular
which simony embodies;
simony crystallizes the real
problem of the crisis of his own
time.
So huge, I repeat,
that it's called the second sin
of Adam.
Dante wrote a political text
called Monarchia,
which is really an argument in
favor of the separation between
these two orders,
the Church and the State:
it had to be neatly divided,
both to protect the State from
the intrusions of the Church and
to protect the Church from the
likely intrusions of the State.
So it's really an argument that
goes in two directions.
So much then for Canto XIX.
The last thing I have to say
because I began talking about
the rhetoric of the prophets,
I said the prophets really used
apostrophes.
Apostrophes which are forms of
lament, "Ah,
Simon,"
you can see it's a kind of
mourning.
It's the language of grief
primarily,
but there is also,
from a linguistic point of
view,
something else about an
apostrophe,
because an apostrophe--it has
in indeterminacy of its own.
It's not really language.
It says nothing.
It's a scream,
but it's the sense of a need to
break the silence.
In other words,
you use an apostrophe or emit a
cry because you cannot be quiet
and that's really exactly what
makes this aspect of prophetic
language so crucial.
It's between silence,
one is overcome by what
one--the enormity of what one
sees and the refusal to
acquiesce.
And I could give you--"Ah
Constantine,"
that's another apostrophe that
we saw.
The whole canto is punctuated
by this rhetorical form that
wants to break the silence and
cannot quite find the words.
That's what I call the
indeterminacy of the rhetorical
artifice.
Let me just go--I know that I
said that I would read XXI;
maybe I can talk about it.
I have to say very little about
comedy.
Dante uses the language of
comedy and what I--
had we time,
I would talk about how Dante
goes out of the way,
in XXI, and says here,
"Now my comedy,
the language,
the humble style."
It is as if he wants to free
himself from the shackles,
the complications of using a
lofty language or taking on this
extraordinary position of being
the prophet of his own times.
He goes on to say,
"my comedy,"
but this comedy is also link to
a peculiar experience that he
tells in Canto XXI:
the fear of falling.
The devils are after him
and--the devils,
of course--he calls them Guelfs
and Ghibellines.
Another way of thinking about
them was the war between,
he says, whites and blacks,
bianchi and neri.
That's the way they would
distinguish themselves.
These demons are--his enemies
are the blacks,
the Ghibellines who are trying
to throw him down,
and the point is that comedy is
always attached,
always flanked with the idea of
the fall.
Laughter, as it were,
begins at the moment when
someone falls,
someone slips and so we could
really talk about that a little
bit more,
but not much more,
if we had a chance to--
if we had a little bit more
time.
I'm anxious to get into XXVI,
and before we get to XXVI,
there is a passage in Canto XXV
that I have to read.
Dante's been going through the
realm of the thieves,
Canto XXIV and XXV,
and he is overwhelmed by the
metamorphosis:
the form of punishment of these
thieves that go on changing
form.
They become snakes.
They are human beings bitten by
snakes, they become snakes,
they turn into ashes,
and they recompose themselves
in an endless cycle.
This is the punishment.
Dante goes on writing as a
poet, breaking the flow of the
narrative of what has been
happening to him,
and this is what he says.
This is from Canto XXV,
lines 90 and following.
He describes the--actually
reading from lines 80 and
following:
"As the lizard under the
great scourge of the dogdays,
passing from hedge to hedge,
seems lightening if it crossed
the way,
so appeared,
making for the bellies of the
other two,
a small fiery serpent,
livid and black as a
peppercorn;
and that part by which we first
received our nourishment,
it transfixed in one of them,
then fell down before him
stretched out.
The one transfixed stared at
it, but said nothing,
only stood still and yawned,
as if sleep or fever had come
upon him.
He kept looking at the serpent
and it at him;
the one from the wound,
the other from the mouth,
smoked violently and their
smoke met."
Now here is Dante talking as a
poet.
He breaks the account,
the chronicle of what he has
seen,
the witnessing since that's
what he is,
he's the witness in all these
experiences and that's what he
says: "Let Lucan now be
silent with his tales of
wretched Sebellus and Nasidius,
and let him wait to hear what
now comes forth.
Let Ovid be silent about Cadmus
and Arethusa;
for if in his lines he turns
him into a serpent and her into
a fountain,
I do not grudge it to him,
for two natures face to face he
never saw transmuted that both
kinds were ready to exchange
their substance."
On the face of it,
Dante's saying that the kind of
metamorphosis he's describing
really is more horrifying than
anything that Ovid,
the author of the
Metamorphosis,
who has always guided his
metamorphosis by a belief in the
bondage,
in the bond of--in the
solidarity between humans,
human beings and the natural
world.
We can go on shifting forms and
there is a kind of serene
transformation happening in
Ovid.
He also says that he's
different from Lucan,
another author of scenes of
metamorphosis in his story about
the civil war.
The point that I think is
really crucial here is that it's
a different one.
Dante is repeating and
reenacting exactly the kind of
aesthetic temptation that we
already witnessed in Canto IV of
Inferno,
in Limbo, where Dante meets the
poets and he's so taken,
so complacent about undoubtedly
the great temptation of sitting
with--
can you imagine--Homer,
Virgil, Horace,
Lucan, Ovid,
exactly the people that he
mentions.
Retrospectively,
that scene of harmony that
Canto IV seemed to dramatize,
now is completely vanquished.
Here he is, he's really saying,
I am their rival,
I am even better,
I'm seeing things that they
didn't even imagine.
If you had the illusion of an
idyllic relationship among
poets, you are disabused at this
point.
It is a temptation nonetheless,
because once again Dante is
going down for--
in a descent,
which is a descent of spiritual
humility,
and yet his voice seems to be
going in an opposite direction,
one of hubris,
the same kind of temptation
that he had in Canto IV.
This is what happens,
again, the structure repeats
itself.
In Canto IV,
Dante claims that he builds
fellowship with the great poets.
He comes into Canto V and he
has to confront the
responsibilities of writing,
the responsibilities of being a
writer and he encounters his
own--
a reader of his own.
Dante merges into Canto XXVI
and meets none other than
Ulysses,
the master rhetorician,
whose experience and whose
journey will lead himself and
his companions to a tragic end.
For Dante this is an
extraordinary moment for a
number of reasons.
Ulysses is a steady point of
reference for his own adventure.
He will keep thinking of him in
Canto XIX of Purgatorio
and in Canto XXVIII of
Paradise,
when Dante is about to live
beyond the whole--
the physical universe.
He looks back to see the
distance he has traveled,
and the only thing that he sees
is really that passageway where
Ulysses violated all boundaries.
Clearly, what kind of
boundaries am I violating?
Ulysses is a mode of being,
a possibility of being,
for Dante himself.
We come into Canto XXVI and I
would like to take as much time
as I possibly can without tiring
you all about this canto.
Let me begin with--as a sort of
preamble--tell you a general
point.
Every school child in antiquity
and in Dante's own time knew one
thing,
that Ulysses was a famous Greek
hero,
polytropic as Homer calls him:
the man of many terms,
a man who knew it all,
the man who had been seasoned
in all experiences.
They know that he had gone to
the War of Troy,
that he was the one to suggest
the building of the Trojan horse
and the stealing of the
Palladium,
as you know,
the simulacrum of Minerva.
Wisdom, the figure of--the
image of wisdom and then it took
him--
that he was involved in the
battle about inheriting
Achilles' arms with Ajax and
then everybody knew that it took
him ten years to return to
Ithaca.
This is the story of the
Odyssey.
He returns, he goes to--we do
know only that the nostos
as the Greeks call it,
the return, the journey of
return.
He becomes the hero of
nostalgia, the going back to a
place that he has.
Everybody knew this in
Dante--in antiquity and in
Dante's time.
In antiquity they knew it very
well because then the story of
Ulysses had become an allegory,
a philosophical allegory of the
fate of the soul.
The idea of Ulysses who goes
from Ithaca to Troy and then
goes back for ten years after a
war of ten years,
another ten years of
vicissitudes,
cleansing himself in order to
reach--
to go back to and testing
himself to go back to his home
town,
was really the story of the
soul.
That's what the soul does.
It incarnates itself,
strophe and
antistrophe,
it goes through--the soul goes
through the planets and gets
tainted by the attributes of the
planets.
Some of us are lunatics,
others are mercurial,
others are saturnine.
That's from the planets,
but then by cleansing ourselves
the soul can go back to its
place of origin.
That's the circle of the return.
That's the way the Alexandrian
neo-Platonists understood the
allegory of the Odyssey.
This is clear.
Dante violates this rule:
that's what you have in Canto
XXVI.
Dante begins with Ulysses who
has returned to Ithaca and
starts his journeys of
exploration all over again.
The idea of the eternal return,
the idea of a closure that he
has come back home,
is not part of Dante's
imagination or sensibility.
He is the poet who is truly
restless and always placing
himself and his heroes on some
kind of quest,
on a method,
on a road, on an address or
whatever the idea,
the philosophers who are always
on--
always thinking about some way
of reaching wisdom,
reaching truth.
That's where he puts them and
that's what happens with the
story of Ulysses.
Ulysses starts all over again
and goes to die.
He's involved in a journey that
is absolutely gratuitous:
a journey for wisdom,
a journey for wisdom into the
unpeopled world.
We're going to see this in a
moment, and he dies.
That's it.
From one point of view--and I
want you to be careful as you
read the canto because you will
see--
you will notice one thing,
the first thing you will notice
that it's not Dante who conducts
the interview with Ulysses.
It is Virgil,
the poet of Latin antiquity and
supposedly they speak maybe
Greek or some form of--clearly
Greek.
It is Virgil,
the poet of the Aeneid
who thinks of himself as the
fitting interlocutor of the
great Greek hero.
Not Dante, Dante's excluded.
Dante just watches and
witnesses this,
but there's more to this idea
of stylistic decorum.
One can say well Virgil--this
is in fact as tragic as a text
could ever get,
sublime.
This is not a comical text,
this is Virgil the author of a
tragedy.
That's what Dante calls it,
the tragic style,
the sublime style,
and Ulysses speaks in the
most--in the loftiest way
possible.
It's not just a question of
stylistic decorum,
at stake there is something
else.
Ulysses disguises himself as
Aeneas and tells the story of
his life as if he were Aeneas.
Now, let me just tell you one
little thing and then we'll get
into the canto.
This is part of the story in
many ways.
If you ask readers of Virgil
and Homer,
they probably will tell
you--well Virgil is a good poet,
but let's face it the first six
books are just the
Odyssey and the second books
are just the Iliad that
he sort of gives a resume of and
so on.
Not at all.
The difference between the two
heroes is this:
Ulysses has a place to go back
to.
He goes from Ithaca to Troy,
back to Ithaca.
Aeneas has no place to go to.
His is the open quest,
the road, on open-ended road,
and open-ended journey and this
is the way Ulysses will think of
himself.
For the last thing,
and then really we'll get into
the canto,
the last thing I'll say is that
the extraordinary ambiguity--
I want to point out the
extraordinary ambiguity with
which Dante represents Ulysses.
But the ambiguity of Ulysses is
part of the story of Ulysses
from the start.
From the very beginning,
Ulysses is a philosopher and he
is a rhetorician.
He is someone who can
manipulate all knowledge for his
own ends, and it is this
ambiguity that in many ways
Dante finds very alluring.
Let me start with the canto.
The canto starts with another
very topical relation,
a very topical allusion.
Dante is drawing their
attention to a specific place,
to the city of Florence.
It is as if he wants to moor
himself, anchor himself to
something as concrete as is
immediate with--immediate place,
his own native place.
And it's an apostrophe to
Florence: "Rejoice
Florence, since thou art so
great."
Let me just stop here a moment.
Pay attention as you read the
canto, pay attention to one
stylistic element:
the antithetical use of 'great'
or 'tall and small' at the same
time.
Rhetorically sometimes,
all with the idea that--
of making us ask and wonder
what is the relationship between
that which claims to be so large
and so big,
and that which claims to be so
small.
Ulysses obviously thinks of
himself in terms of loftiness
and Dante now rhetorically
starts with Florence:
"so great,"
the satire is obvious,
"that over land and sea
thou beatest thy wings and
through Hell thy name is spread
abroad."
The whole point is that he has
seen some Florentine thieves,
and named even:
"Among the thieves...
five such citizens of thine
that shame for them comes."
Once again the prophetic voice
of Dante appears here and you
will see that this is fairly
important in the narrative.
Second paragraph,
"We set out,
and, on the stairs which the
projecting rocks had made for a
descent before,
my Leader mounted again and
drew me up,
and, following the lonely way
among the rocks and splinters of
the ridge,
the foot made no speed without
the hand.
I grieved then and grieve now
anew"--;then,
when he was a pilgrim,
watching and witnessing the
stories that he is going to
tell.
And now, as a writer.
There's a double focus that
Dante's using:
the focus of the pilgrim and
the focus of the narrator.
"I grieved then and I
grieve now anew when I turn my
mind to what I saw,
and more than I am wont I curb
my powers."
And this is going to be at
least the attempt of Dante to
curb his powers as he witnesses
the story of immoderate hunger
for knowledge of a flight of the
mind.
That's what we have here.
The flight of the mind which is
like the flight of Daedalus,
which is like the flight of
Icarus that seems to know no
boundaries.
Ulysses is he who transgresses
all boundaries,
but doesn't Dante also
transgress boundaries?
He won't say so here,
he wants--it seems that he
takes Ulysses as an exemplary
figure that would lead him
to--one to curb his powers.
Let's continue,
"lest they run where
virtue does not guide
them."
The language is that of horses,
of course, the horses of the
soul.
And virtue is the ability to
hold the black and the white
horse of the chariot,
to hold them together
and--that's the allusion that
Dante is using in neo-Platonic
language.
"If favoring star or
something better have granted me
such boon, I may not grudge it
to myself."
Now, the first description of
the landscape:
a somber landscape,
"as many as the fireflies
which the peasant resting on the
hill--
in the season when he that
lights the world least hides his
face from us..."
What an extraordinary image,
a periphrasis,
to talk about the sun,
to describe the night,
when the sun is hiding,
and you'll see the implications
of this metaphor--
I hope--in a moment.
"Sees along the valley
below, in the fields,
perhaps, where he gathers the
grapes and tills;
with so many flames the eighth
ditch was all gleaming,
as I perceived as soon as I
came where the bottom was in
sight.
And as he that was avenged by
the bears saw the chariot of
Elijah at his departure when the
horses reared and rose to
heaven,
who could not follow it with
his eyes so as to see anything
but the flame alone like a
little cloud mounting up;
so each flame moves along the
gullet of the ditch,
for none shows the theft and
every one steals away a
sinner."
Dante's not comparing himself
to Elijah, he's comparing to
someone who watches Elijah.
Elijah is also engaged in a
flight to--
a flight of the soul,
exactly like Ulysses who is
going to be represented as--
is the antithesis to Ulysses,
but Dante is neither like
Elijah and he would like us to
believe that he's not really
like Ulysses.
He is like Eliseus,
the one who inherits the mantle
of prophecy from Elijah,
and the one who witnesses,
who watches.
It's his way of trying to avoid
the extreme of the prophet and
now, as it turns out,
the rhetorician.
This is the way the layout here
is between Ulysses and Elijah.
"I was standing on the
bridge,"
and then he goes on.
He's told that within the
flames are the spirits.
There's a forked flame and
there are two souls:
Ulysses and Diomedes.
Pay attention to this little
detail.
Except in the case of the
suicides, Dante always sees
pairs of sinners.
Here's Diomedes who doesn't
talk and he sees also Ulysses,
and I suppose that the reason
is that Dante really wants us to
know about the social quality of
a moral violation,
that a moral violation always
implies somebody else.
It's not quite ever--except for
the suicide which has a peculiar
form because you have witness,
homicide, and victim all in
one--but in the other sinners
you always have a sense of a
witness,
somebody else who has been
touched or an accomplice of the
sinner.
"Within,"
we know what he answered who
are these people.
"I already wished to ask
thee who is in that fire which
comes so cloven at the top that
seems to rise from the pyre with
Eteocles was laid with his
brother."
The story is the
Thebaid,
the two brothers were enemies,
Eteocles and Polyneices,
Thebes--we already have an
introduction of--
this is all about Greek
mythology.
In Greek mythology with
brothers--the city of--
the story of Thebes which Dante
knows through Statius,
the idea of Oedipus,
of course and Jocasta,
and the tragic city.
The Thebes becomes the term,
becomes the metaphor,
the basic metaphor of the
tragic city because in effect it
presents also--
one of the reasons for Dante
it's crucial,
it presents birth,
Eteocles and Polyneices,
the children of Oedipus and
Jocasta,
as tragic events.
This is something that
distinguishes radically the
Greek idea,
as Dante understands it,
the Greek idea of cities and
birth from say,
Virgil's idea of birth,
something to be celebrated all
the time and Virgil is always
the one who celebrates the
birth-- Assinius Pollio,
etc.
Now we know who these are.
"He answered me:
'Within there are tormented,
Ulysses and Diomed,
and thus together they go under
vengeance as once under
wrath..."
etc.
"'If they're able to speak
within these lights,' I said,
'I earnestly pray thee,
Master, and pray again that my
prayer avail a thousandfold that
thou do not forbid me to stay
tils the horned flame comes
near;
thou seest how I bend toward it
with desire.'
And he said to me,
'Thy prayer deserves much
praise, therefore I consent to
it.
But do thou restrain thy
tongue.'"
Earlier he wanted to curb his
powers,
now Virgil asks him to restrain
his tongue,
"Leave it to me to speak,
for I have understood what thou
wishest;
for perhaps,
since they were Greeks,
they would disdain thy
speech."
We have really a sense of the
hierarchy of styles:
Virgil and Ulysses,
and then in Canto XXVII it's
going to be Guido da Montefeltro
and Dante.
"You who are two within
one fire,
if I deserved of you while I
lived,
if I deserved of you much or
little,"
once again,
the oscillation between high
and low,
"much or little,
when in the world I wrote the
lofty lines,
do not move on,
but let the one of you tell
where,
being lost, he went to die.'
The greater horn of the ancient
flame began to toss and murmur,
just as if it were beaten by
the wind,
then, waving the point to and
fro as if it were the tongue
that spoke,
it flung forth a voice and
said: 'When I parted from Circe,
who held me more than a year
near Gaeta before Aeneas so
named it,"
so you see clearly Ulysses
tells his story through the myth
of Aeneas.
Claiming priority over Aeneas,
but also the knowledge in one
thing.
It's an incredibly--I find it a
very moving line that Aeneas
names places in memory of his
nurse.
He names the city of Gaeta,
he's a founder of cities,
and names the city of Gaeta.
"Not fondness for his son,
not duty to an aged father,
not the love I owed
Penelope..."
Look at this,
it's what we call heavily
ethical language.
Ulysses speaks in terms of what
his duties are:
the duty to an aged father
Laertes,
"the love I owed Penelope,
which should have gladdened
her, could conquer within me the
passion I had to gain experience
of the world and of the vices
and the worth of men."
This is--seems to be an ethical
quest and nothing can stand in
the way of this virtuous action.
Ulysses thinks of himself as a
virtuous quester after vices,
understanding and gaining
experience "..
.of vices and virtues and the
worth of men;
and I put forth on the open
deep with but one ship...
The one shore and the other I
saw as far as Spain...
Morocco...
Sardinia..."
And he's a man of--mentions
places all the time,
in this narrative.
He always mentions places,
cities, Morocco,
Seville, Ceuta on the other
side of the Mediterranean.
It is as if here is a man who
lives in space.
He left his father,
he left his son,
that would be temporal
description of him,
but he lives in space.
It's as if he never really knew
his own place in the world.
He's always looking for
something, he doesn't even--he
doesn't know where he belongs.
"My companions were old
and slow when we came to that
narrow outlet where Hercules set
up his landmarks so that men
should not pass beyond.
On my right hand I left
Seville, on the other had
already left Ceuta."
And now the speech he makes to
his own companions.
Look at the rhetorical wisdom
with which he moves.
He addresses them as brothers
which is the biggest captatio
benevolentiae:
we are all together,
there is no hierarchy here,
I'm not your leader,
I'm not your king:
"O brothers,' I said,
'who through a hundred thousand
perils,"
look at the hyperboles.
If you want to seduce people to
come,
companions to come with you,
you have to tell them they--
that theirs are mighty actions
and he does,
and then magnify all the
possible dangers.
"A hundred thousand perils
have reached the west,"
not a definite place,
the west, vague and yet lofty,
"to this so brief vigil of
the senses."
The modesty,
the oscillation between
hyperbole and litotes,
as it were, the recoiling into
the sense of ordinariness and
small.
"That remains to us,
choose not to deny
experience,"
which I find an extraordinary
word,
an experience,
and I probably will stop here
with this.
Experience, as you know,
is a word only with
prepositions,
experire.
It's a journey,
it's a going through,
an experience.
It's understood as a journey,
it is as if knowledge--that's
the etymology of the word is,
it's a going through.
If knowledge literally is
compared to a displacement
through a traveling,
through a katabasis even,
in this case,
which is the term to indicate
the descent into the beyond.
"In the sun's tracks of
the unpeopled world.
Take thought of the seed from
which you spread."
If you want to know the end of
things you have to know the
beginnings, you have to know the
seeds.
This is the--his is Ulysses'
perception and because you have
a noble seed then you do know
that you are--
there's a kind of natural
determination in his own mind
that he will reach,
indeed, the noble end.
"You were not born to live
as brutes, but to follow virtue
and knowledge."
That's an extraordinary line.
He promises that human beings
will leave behind--
the allusion maybe to the
metamorphosis of Circe,
that had changed the companions
into pigs,
the Epicureans,
the hogs of Epicurus into the
voluptuary experiences--
and he promises to restore in
them not only the human image
but to bring them to virtue,
knowledge.
It's an extraordinary promise;
it's a very difficult promise.
It's almost an impossible
promise;
it may even not be a correct
promise, because he's making a
promise that virtue is
knowledge.
I lead you to virtue and
knowledge, and they may not be
the same thing.
I may have knowledge,
but it doesn't mean that I have
the virtue that I claim to have
knowledge about.
It could be anything,
anything at all.
I can know what prudence is.
It doesn't--that doesn't really
make me prudent.
Let's stop here,
I want to stop here and I want
to see if there are some
questions and then resume next
time with the canto.
Yes?
Student:
>
with Aeneas--with Ulysses
because they both aren't going
to any definite place.
Is that what you said?
Aeneas is like Ulysses because
they both don't have a definite
place to return to?
Prof: The question is,
I mentioned--actually Ulysses
mentions knowing that he speaks
to Virgil,
mentions Aeneas and so that's
the answer,
why Aeneas and Ulysses vaguely.
That's the--they clearly were
fighting the same battle in
Troy.
Virgil--Ulysses must know that
Aeneas had lost his home town
and he took his son,
unlike Ulysses,
he took his father on his back
literally,
he's an immigrant and his son
and lost his wife Creusa,
and goes looking for a place
without really knowing what
place for him.
Ulysses knows where he wants to
go;
he has a certain idea of his
destination, which is Ithaca.
He has a lot of temptations
along the way:
Nausicaa, and what a
temptation;
Circe, another great temptation.
He manages to move beyond those
temptations in order to go back
to Ithaca.
That's the great difference
from the Roman myth of the
immigrant.
Student:  But in this
version aren't they still really
different because Ulysses
doesn't--
I mean he--his quest doesn't
have any direction at all,
it's just experience,
and Aeneas' quest,
he doesn't know where he's
going but there's still an
overall plan so that there is a
definite
>.
Prof: Exactly,
absolutely, so there is a--the
difference between them becomes
that Aeneas will stop at one
point.
He has temptations to stop in
Sicily,
you remember that there are
famous games,
the games--ritual games in
memory of his father who had
died,
the death that hallows that
ground,
the death of Anchises,
the women burn the ships--
this is too--this is utopia.
I don't--we don't want to go
around into this epic adventure,
let's stop here,
he won't.
He's always misunderstanding
oracles.
He doesn't know where to go.
He's always looking backwards,
but looking forward at the same
time, but at one point he stops.
And that's part of,
if you wish,
the realism of Aeneas.
He stops at one point;
he will not go any further.
Ulysses goes back home and then
he starts all over again,
but that's Dante reading of
Ulysses.
He's really reading him as very
much like, as if he were a
variant of Dante by the way.
Yes?
Student:  Is it possible
for Ulysses and Aeneas to
represent the dichotomy between
Dante the poet and Dante the
narrator?
One has a definite place as
looking back and has a definite
place where he's going and the
other is taking a journey of
experience and is not sure where
he's going?
Prof: The question is
very interesting and is it
possible to think of Aeneas and
Ulysses as two functions,
as it were, of Dante:
the pilgrim and the poet.
Yes and no.
It's a very interesting
question, but I would not--I
really hesitate to agree with
you for one reason.
Because writing,
for Dante, is a prolongation of
the search.
Dante literally cannot stop.
It's not that he--on the face
of it, he has seen the beatific
vision, right,
that's really the story.
A story of a man who goes from
the wilderness,
goes through Hell,
Purgatory, Paradise,
and has a beatific vision and
now he starts telling us about
it.
Fighting against forgetfulness,
he has a lot of--
as a writer,
he has a lot of temptations and
yet the writing itself is
fraught with dangers,
temptations.
It's a different sort of
journey, but it's the journey of
writing and therefore there's no
clear-cut distinction between
the two.
In fact, I just read in Canto
XXV the little scene when he
challenges Lucan and Ovid,
which really is,
let the past yield to the
present,
that's really the kind of claim
that they can make.
Let them be quiet,
because I know what is
happening and the story is that
as a writer he is lapsing,
he is falling into a number of
temptations,
as if he were a pilgrim.
You can expect that from a
pilgrim, to being fascinated by
Francesca, having all these
inner divisions.
Dante is a deeply divided man,
he has to condemn and at the
same time has to sympathize even
as a pilgrim.
So that's really the--that's
the only little detail where I
would not agree with you,
but maybe you're right,
I don't know.
Yes?
Student:  Can you speak
about the fact that Dante
changes the ending because his
story's
>
in Ithaca and why he
>.
Prof: The question is,
can I speak about how Dante
changes the ending of Ulysses'
story?
The answer is this.
Dante makes Ulysses go back to
Ithaca, but then he breaks the
circle of this closed
circle--let's call it the circle
of the epic.
Let me talk formally about it.
The idea is that you--what are
some traits of the epic?
The epics deal with foundations
of cities and destruction of
cities, all the time,
no matter what that city may
be.
So he has destroyed the city,
goes back to his old city to
cleanse it.
That's--which is Homer's way of
saying--
I think--you Greeks were so
great when you went out into the
world at Troy,
let us see how that heroic
ethos is going to help you now
that you are back home,
where probably you are going to
need more courage and more
determination--
as much courage,
at least as much determination
as you did have in that great
celebration of the newly found
Greek unity in Asia Minor in
Troy.
That's--Dante takes that and he
says, there's no closure here,
because he rejects the idea of
Dante.
To the epic he replaces the
epic with the novel.
This becomes a kind of
novelistic story,
wherein experience is being
arrived at, as one goes.
You see what I'm saying?
In the epic you have a kind
of--indeed things return to the
point of departure,
so that's the difference.
It's a difference between two
radically different ways of
understanding experience and the
self.
Dante will put himself on the
open road, but Ulysses will
remain the constant reminder to
him.
He's a phantasm,
he can never quite exorcise.
It will return to him,
as I said, when a siren appears
and tempts the pilgrim and says
look I made--
I gave happiness to Ulysses,
why don't you stay with me?
And the implication is,
first of all,
she's lying because this is the
story of Ulysses putting the wax
in his ears,
which is nicely omitted,
but it's in a way a temptation
to Dante to feel that he,
too, is an epic hero like
Ulysses.
Did I answer?
Other questions?
We'll come back to this canto
which is--
truly plays a crucial role in
Dante's imagination and in
the Divine Comedy,
the unfolding of the Divine
Comedy,
so read carefully and then
we'll go onto the other cantos.
Thank you.